foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
Roma domains in HPV head and neck cancer
using NGS to help understand the
transcriptional landscape this webinar
is part of the 10th Annual cancer
research and immuno oncology week and
I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
tcan for more information about tcam go
to tcam.com now let's get started before
we begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other identities
using our new live chat feature during
the presentation you can find that live
chat located on the left of your screen
you can also participate submitting as
many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit in addition to asking questions
we encourage you to participate in three
poll questions at the end of our
speaker's presentation click on your
answer when the poll questions are
displayed now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the help desk button located at
the top of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present today's speaker Dr gopol Iyer
for a complete biography of our speakers
please visit the printer tab from the
menu on the left of the screen Dr gopal
ire welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you good morning everybody
my name is gopal Ayer I'm an assistant
professor at the department of human
oncology
at the University of Wisconsin-Madison
you can see this beautiful Lake over
here
it's called Lake Mendota this is the
entire Campus located
all around the lake
and it's a beautiful time to be here in
the summer I invite to all of you over
here
and also if you like to ski and do ice
fishing on a frozen lake you're welcome
in the winter as well
so my lab is basically focused on HPV
head and neck cancer
and we have another project which study
long brain metastasis
and we are asking the question why do
primary lung tumor cells prefer to go to
the brain
While others some of the other cancer
cell types
do not prefer to
establish in the brain and colonize to
cosmetises
so
I'm going to talk to you about the
biology of HPV infection head and cancer
in this talk
followed by the relevance of proteins
harboring Brahma domains and viral host
transcription
and discuss to you some of the findings
of the transcriptal regulation while
hosting interactions
uh
the work is made possible because there
was a beautiful instrument that was
introduced by
tcam which allowed me to actually be
very reproducible
l in terms of generating libraries
for sequencing which can be quite
challenging
if you are a lab that are involved in
making your own libraries
I will talk about this later as we go
ahead on The Talk
and uh
so
I am interested in bromo domain and
exothermal proteins
and that is involved in various cellular
processes as you can see in the slide
from a basic science perspective it's
involved in embryonic development cell
differentiation transcriptional
regulation
also in modern evolutionary there's some
evolutionary questions about Brahma
domains
from a clinical perspective or a
translational perspective that involved
also in call
regulating transcription and during a
viral infection
and also a normal viral transcription as
well
it's also more than not been like
carcinoma
and that has essentially spun off a
field
uh which developing small molecule
Inhibitors against these bad proteins
and also trying to understand
epigenetic regulation and animal models
as well from a therapeutic standpoint
and these Inhibitors now have spun off
into approximately about 39 clinical
trials around the world
simply trying to ask a question
how
can we use bet Inhibitors to prevent
transcription of key oncogenes
in various kinds of cancers
so the reason I say clock before the
horses because
sometimes some of these better
Inhibitors that have been introduced
have
shown some effects but mechanistically
uh has not been completely addressed
because bet Inhibitors cause various
a type of inhibition of
from standard
uh transcription to non-transcriptional
mode as well so I think sometimes it's
better to also understand some of the
basic questions before to produce a
clinical trials but I do understand why
it should be pushed in a clinical as
well
because you want to solve
or at least find a therapeutic endpoint
for some of these cancers that are
debilitating
um
so essentially there I'm gonna the
anatomy of the head and neck cancer
is primarily for the HPV resides here is
in the pharynx region
which is essentially called the nasal
pharynx oropharynx and the hypotherings
so this is where HP resides and if you
were to take a swab out of this region
you can actually stand for p16 which is
a surrogate marker for HPV
um which is a completely different story
but that's how it has been done here
and uh
and I'm going to focus on hpv16 which is
a high-risk HTTP subtype and head and
neck cancer
and it is a predominantly increasing in
younger individuals in North America and
Europe because of lifestyle changes and
so on
and so which is
important for us to find ways to
dampen the HPV infection
and we will look into that
some of the ideas that I'll present in
the stock might be interesting
to pursue worldwide as well
so the biology HPV 16 infected cells
essentially yeah
starts at the tonsillar Crypt
and you can see an expansion as I
expanded this one over here
um the cells
the
HPV infection occurs through this basal
layer
then you have stem cell differentiation
over here
and then you have a dysplastic condition
followed by carcinoma
and then the carcinoma and situ then
gets transformed into an invasive
carcinoma
so
but the molecular
characteristics are that that you have
an E6 E7 that is contributed by the
virus
uh that then
also has some effects on p53 and RB
which we'll talk about in that relates
to our district regulated cell cycle
2 e to F1
and you have this plastic condition so
primarily
which have been identified to trapped
three are fit in P10
and then there are some mutations that
have been identified in p3ca and some
aberrant expression of Sox 20 in tumor
which is essentially what causes the
cancer heal
so
the HPV is an 8kb genome it resides as
an episomal state
it has about eight genes primarily
and the e6e7up critical are known to be
oncogenic as well because the control
the cellular PhD and RB tumors
impressive genes however this episomal
genes episode genome
integrates into the host and and the way
it integrates is that typically through
the E2 or E1 region and linearizes and
integrates into the HPV
cycle and then into
do the host
and eventually becomes part of the host
of machinery
uh during cell cycle and so on so you do
have integration occurring in randomly
you could have an integration in
enhanced regions
you can have Integrations in ketogenic
regions you can have Integrations
important tumor suppressor genes but
these are all very uh stochastic and so
that's what makes it very interesting in
terms of understanding
other integration effects
on causing the
proliferation of these cancers not these
cancer cells
so
so look what we are interested in here
is that what are these promo domain
containing proteins BRD 2 3 and 4 and
how are they relevant for HPV cancers
so there are about 46 diverse proteins
there are 61 bromer domains
which are structurally clustered dry
testing sub families
we will just focus on this
uh family two
which consists of brd3 brd2 brd4
and uh and see how they are relevant
in
with they had an account
so
primarily the ability for a long isoform
the brd4 short isoform the brd3 and brd2
the viral protein E2 uh
positowness and
peptide of this was called crystallized
with acetamination of the brd4 long
isoform
bd1 and bd2 are the domains that are
involved in a co-regulating
transcription
there is a also interestingly the brd4
short isoform is also known to interact
with virally to protein
of hpv31 which is interesting because it
does not have the C terminal in but
somehow is being identified turned right
hpv31
um
there's also
the a which is has a NLS and B which is
also
uh involves in hetero and Homo
diameterization as well and the
exothermal domain is also a portable
interaction
uh with other known model
of
viruses with like kshv and MLB and so on
so
um
so the functional significance of these
bomber domains are that these Brownwood
domain uh contain proteins can recognize
acetylated
lysines on histones on nucleosomes
and can
then co-regulate transcription and in
this particular case important disease
like bcl2 cdk 6 and cmic uh are actually
oh
a regulated by prd4 along with other
transcriptional components here
however the claim to fame uh for
inhibiting C Mick which is a
non-druggable target for a long time
was with the Advent of these pet
Inhibitors which could then block
this brd4 to bind to this isolated
nuclear zones which were looked situated
on these Target genes like semic and
silicon bcl2 and block transcription and
so this was important
Discovery and that spun off a whole
field of
of epigenetic Inhibitors targeting brd4
or bad proteins essentially
so
in the context of HPV brd4 is essential
for tethering E2 to isolated nucleosomes
and this is an episomal State and then
it tethers to this
oscillator nucleosomes and is known to
regulate
mitosis
as well
so
but however the multiple interactions
that were associated with the prd4 long
isoform
also led to the question can we develop
nanomolar Inhibitors and indeed there
are some animal or inhibitors
that have been developed to Target the
brd4 long isoform
and as you can see over here
there is the E2 interaction
that interacts with bd2 as well and then
here you have E2 that interact with C
Thomas and that however most of the
Inhibitors Target the bd1 and bd2
domains of pet proteins
uh there are some other
transcriptional call regulators and
activators that have been identified
that interact with brd4 long isoform
and it is of interest to actually
inhibit some of these activity
so that you can then down regulate some
of the target genes that uh recruit some
of these
uh transcriptional correlators and
activators
um
so we looked at this from a context of
can it be used
these Inhibitors can be used for
regulating some of the viral and host
genes and header neck cancer
that were infected with xpv-16
and so what we were interested is in
this particular State the integrated
state
where you have high stromal activities
which induces and which induces worse
survival rates as well
and you can also have low stromal
activity which also creates a
collaborative signature
so while as you can see over here the
epistomal state has a better survival
rate while the integrated state has a
worse survival rate so we were mostly
interested in the integrated HPV
populations
and so for that
we asked some of the questions before
HPV also
HPV proteins regulate some of the tumor
suppressors like p53 and RB as well and
so they sequester it to degradation and
that leads to number and cell cycle
while if you look at the normal
physiological pathway you don't see a
lot of changes associated
uh
because it will have p53
and E12 there's a very nice cell cycle
regulation associated
with the normal physiological state
uh while as an HPB it is controlled by
E6 and E7
so
we then curated the HPV tcga database
and simply ask the question are these
cancers
this patient is addicted to a bad
transcriptural activity and lo and
behold if you look at the transcription
TPMS
a lot of these patients do over Express
brd2 br3 and brd4 that led us to the
question
can we use beta Inhibitors to Target
these brd4
and brd2 and very three activity as well
so then what we did is we took a bunch
of a panel of cell lines which were
actually being infected which we
characterized for the for integration
status
and they were all sensitive to the best
inhibitor jq1
which is a pan button a bitter and also
you can see that they're also in
sensitize
them at no low nanomolar to high in
animal or
ic50s however one of the interesting
things was that
um
uh brd2 was upregulated
while brd4
was early effects were down regulated
but then we chosen effect which is
expected because
it does not
self-regulate itself at this stage
didn't look like that
but uh
this is more like a
protein effects
prd4 Innovation through jq1
so then we looked at from a localization
perspective brd4 was fairly present all
over the place
um which is expected but surprisingly
enough brd2 actually one and got
sequestered and reasons where tappy was
not stained
and operated fractal regions you see a
brd2 located
was sequestered into that and we do not
know it currently as to why that we're
exploring the idea of why this brd2 goes
and sequesters in
this dappy refractile regions
so
then we asked the question if we down
regulate sh of prd4 do they also affect
viral genes like e2e6 and E7
and as it was interestingly enough brd4
down regulation through sh knockdown
also control z67
and suggesting that it also phenopopies
the effect of the small molecular
inhibitor jq1 as well
so essentially this result basically led
us to the idea that we should understand
the overall transcriptome of these cells
as to what are the differences
and does brd4 actually control e67
uh the viral
genome as well and so
and then we then went back and we were
trying to make a lot of libraries
and the president obviously the
presented itself with tcan
and this is the the beautiful t-can
machine which looks essentially like an
extended PCR machine
where you essentially
add your RNA sample and magically
something happens
and it generates you consistent
libraries without any hiccups
uh
the the machine essentially recognizes
these reagent cartridges it has magnetic
beads it has a lot of sample deck
components
it has all the things that you need to
do a library prep
uh including tips and tubes
which you don't necessarily have to do
anything
and it is very intuitive and it
eliminates a lot of the the samples
inconsistencies in the library Preps
that arises due to you know having to
pull it off a magnetic rack and making
on and off and so on and so forth
so
the the setup time is essentially you
know you just load the RNA sample and if
you have DNA you can do that as well
and you can just walk away from it
and uh it's a fully integrated system
where you can actually just you know
essentially have everything
completely automated and you can go and
have a good time
while the library is being made
uh it has a lot of uh it has a usual
frame and stand
the samples goes here in the first row
and it has all the beads and so on it's
already pre-mixed
does bulk creations and also the waste
and it also has tips
so you just load the whole thing over
into this cassette and then you start
the machine
and you essentially
press this magical button over here
and you walk away and you come back up
to 10 hours
to get your RNA libraries
and for DNA I think it's around close to
six hours
it's pretty neat uh it has sold a lot of
our
challenges that we have had especially
when you're dealing with patient samples
which are very precious
uh you can do anywhere between ten to
thousand nanograms it does the usual
steps that you have located
you know Mana Library Preps
but
you don't have to podcast that's what
I'm trying to get at so you just have to
walk away with just inputting this RNA
and it will do all these steps of
fragmentation reverse transcriptase
purification
prepare
adapter ligation barcoding and so on and
so forth and
you get
a very neat Library
at the end of it so in our case we were
very surprised to see that all our
triplicates matched consistently and
there was a very good coverage
five parameter three prime transcript
coverage
and which is fairly surprising because
when we've done this manually
this was not the case and this made life
very easy
and your total sequencing cost comes
down to almost like fifty dollars
per sample as opposed to something that
could run into hundreds
um
we were also surprised that when you
compared this to the k562 control
samples
uh they were quite similar
in terms of the coverage
and which was very good
and we were fairly happy because all our
samples are here and also here
and they were fairly consistent with
the control samples as well
if you look at there was also a very
high correlation between the technical
replicates when we did
no
the control samples which led us to
believe that this would also be the case
for our experimental samples as well
so
uh
so when we also have low Library
fields of
or rather when we had low input
we are also able to get very good
uh
Library preps out of that as well so we
wanted to see if we loaded low amount of
RNA could we also get similar
High libraries as well so we were very
surprised and we were very happy with it
so that uh
reduced a lot of our headaches into the
manual Library prep so
it can also do intact DNA but you can
also do fragments DNA it and also the
MRNA
and so we
've done most of we've done quite a bit
of work with this and so we'll fairly
consistently surprised as to the quality
of what we can get out of this
um so
then we ask the question
um
what happens
when we do the
compared to the manual RNA mrnac
workflow
you have all these different steps
it would take you about seven hours
while in a magic ngsm RNA is equal to
your sample prep time is only 10 minutes
and then you just walk away
and the libraries are made essentially
after 10 hours
but you if you feel like doing something
else with your life you can potentially
hold your samples up to 65 hours within
the machine and nothing goes awry with
the libraries
um it frees up time for doing other
things as well
um so for the dnic as well this is the
same thing you have 50 to 500 nanograms
it will do all the essential steps that
what you do from your manual Library
prep
and you can walk several workflows
available
which will allow you to do high quality
DNA pre-fragmented DNA cell free DNA and
so on and so forth as well
um so to just to summarize uh why we
chose to run with tcan and how it made
our life easier to understand our HPV
biology
in terms of transcription and transcript
homes and so on
uh
the success rate was fairly astounding
compared to
the manual Library prep although you
could still get good libraries but
I was more interested to make sure that
I could get this
in and out time and time again the same
quality as opposed to
having to have some good and some bad
libraries
uh do you have
typically you don't need any expertise
you just need to load the cassette with
the reagents
and then you can just walk away
um so
yeah there's a lot of things positive
aspects of this I would strongly think
that you should test it out
uh simply because it's just reproducible
and for me
and for us in the lab we would like to
produce
consistently good Library so that we are
confident of what we are stating and
interpreting the data
[Music]
um
so then we come back to the biology so
the question here is
um while the HPV integrates into the
genome we want to ask a question using
these libraries and the sequencing data
that we obtained
how do we
identify what the HPV reads are so we
adopted something called a discard and
read pair where you can actually then
identify
where exactly in the Genome of the host
have the integrated number one and then
you can also identify from that region
how many recounts do you get for your
individual vital genes
so you do something which is you know I
just got a repair
and you can identify
your
vital Gene and also the host Gene and
understand
you know how whether these uh
genes
are co-regulated by brd4
transcriptionally
in the presence of the inhibitor or not
and then
we were very surprised to see that
um when we did something called
a nested PCR that the HPV Journal was
actually disrupted in the trump in the
E2 region
while the
sec2 cells were not destructed in the
uturian they were full length
and we were able to actually actually
map the recounts and we identify it was
integrating the X chromosome of a Kill
until it was uh integrated in this
particular case in chromosome 3.
and interestingly enough
um
it's suggested to us that there was some
integration dependent effects on how
brd4 co-regulates transcription
because if you look at
the DIA PH2 Gene
in both the cases
BR4 did not seem to regulate di pH 2
Gene co-regular diph2 Gene while
brd4 dip
co-regulate tp63 and in the presence of
the inhibitor down regulated
significantly
uh the
host Gene as well
so along with the data that I showed you
that E2 E6 E7 was also down regulated we
also identified that uh
where wherever the insertion did occur
in the host the cellular Gene also was
down regulated at 363
so what suggested to us that there was
some integration to pattern defects
occurring
and brd4 selectively co-regulates
some of the whole streams as well
uh
in this particular case
so we also looked at all the other uh
the genes that we were involved
interested in
so you could see here that at the
protein level
whatever they will eat was disrupted or
e67 was down regulated while when it was
not disrupted there was no
change
so
uh in the e67
which led us to believe that there
should be could be the integration of
the wild genome affected
how the
p67 was regulated
by brd4 and in turn also could be
uh
regulated by E2 which is supposed to
also have some effects on E6 and E7
uh activation uh
as described in the literature
so interestingly here the point to note
here is that E6 and E7 gets down
regulated significantly
while in this particular case in this
particular line E2 E6 E7 one not
um
significantly
down regulated but in fact they seem to
be upregulated
to a certain extent in in the presence
of although they are not statistically
significant what is more interesting
here is that uh cmic was down regulated
at 24 hours here
while cmic was not down regulated in the
presence of to jq1 inhibitor as well so
so overall it's suggested to us that
uh
P6 186 and E7 was down related as RB and
53 was also down regulated
and while in this particular case
um
RB and 53 had no signal were not
significantly affected at 24 hours
as you can see over here so which
suggested to us that there must be
something going on
uh
in the in this particular case and which
you're trying to explore at this moment
and you can see from a protein
perspective as well that previously
actually comes back to tumor suppressor
activity comes back on
and which is also
very interesting while despite the brief
[Music]
the p53 and RB
uh coming back up in this particular
case in in the full lengthy 2 the RB
was also coming back up
but had no significant impact uh towards
cell cycle
uh which I'll show you uh in the
subsequent slides so in case the summary
here is that
uh in truncated E2 cells brd4 regulator
367 independently
in full length E2 brd4 has no
significant impact on E6 and A7
transcription I mean the whole side
while Whenever there is an integration
disruption brd4 significantly dollar AC
to F1 as well we are independently
evaluating this in other lines as well
and it seems to
suggest that
integration plays a role
and uh how jq1 interacts with brd4
in other cases as well
so the questions that we are interested
to ask is why did e67 not alter RB and
uh uh why was
uh HPV not impacted by brd4 regulation
and full lately to expressing cells
um
when we looked at the cell cycle
interestingly enough
Whenever there was a down regulation of
p6e7 as understandably there was a G1
arrest
uh significant do you want to rest
up to 48 hours while if you look at uh
the full length there is a
a significant
G1 which is consistently hovering around
50 percent but there was doesn't seem to
be any cycling of the
sng two phase as well so suggesting that
there are some other
non-rb 53 effects going on so when we
looked at the overall RNA sequencing
profile
we recognize that
uh homologous recombination mismatch
repair cell cycle was significantly
uh
affected
in the case of the
truncated E2 while in the full length A2
there was no significant impact
so it looks like the integration affects
the cell cycle in global RNA
transcription as well
which we are actively pursuing in terms
of understanding how it occurs
so then we asked
can we ask
can be actually used as in the context
of radiation because you know currently
in the clinic the standard of care
treatment is HP patient which is
platinum so then we then simply ask a
question how do better Inhibitors
directly impact DNA repair genes
and can we use the escalation of
radiation dollars with better innovation
as a potential alternative treatment
so then what we did is we did a standard
clonogenic assay where you radiate cells
with different dose of radiation
and you make a clinogenic survival assay
and we identify that sixth ways did seem
to have an impact as well uh
on the survival of these cells
so then we looked at all these different
DNA repair components
because typically you cannot have
mutually exclusive non homologous and
joining or homologous recombination
occurring in a Cell so they are all tied
in intimately
but we were very surprised to see that
in the presence of jq1
there was and radiation there was a
significant down regulation of
these MRE 11
nbs1 and Route 51 as well
which is very surprising because it
suggests that they should in combination
with the radiation
jq1 seemed to somehow impact some of
these DNA repair genes as well
and so then we asked the question what
should we do in terms of how do we assay
this so we looked at Gamma S2 extra
formation
and we were surprised that we could
still see the gamma h2x full size still
being retained
at 24 hours and more of this was
retained suggesting that the repair
activity was delayed which suggests to
us that if you can actually add a better
inhibitor plus radiation you can extend
uh
the
instability of the Genome of these
cancer cells because now you don't have
to
these cells cannot repair efficiently
uh
as it's which is a favorable outcome
when you want to treat patients
so
then we summarize this uh this
preliminary results and then we identify
that simic create cell cycle rest in G1
and truncated to expressing cells
the RNA sequencing profile option carry
each one full length were very distinct
and transcriptional layer of hygienes
are impacted in truncularity to cells
more significantly than the full length
so
we are trying to identify whether uh if
we can compare this with radiation is
this a potential route for creating
genomic instability
because obviously that Innovation is not
sufficient enough
to create long-term instability and you
need this radiation as a hammer
to exacerbate this instability in this
genomes
so
uh
over
currently now we are also exploring a
new
formative and specific Inhibitors these
are second iterations
they have been recently published and
they have had
a very interesting take because you can
actually selectively
in a bit bd1 and bd2
and simply ask a question how do they
affect Target genes as well so we're
exploring this in the context of HPV as
well
by using the selective bb1 and bd2
inhibitors
so that is what I have to talk about and
I can tell you that a lot of just
transcriptional output
data that we have had was extensively
enabled by using this tcan machine
which would have not been possible
or rather it gave us more confidence
uh in terms of how libraries were made
using that machine
I'd like to thank
for your time and the primary players
were this lady Akasha Rao
who was uh
in my lab and now has moved on to be a
grad student
Alberta's bio medical engineering
student graduate student in the lab
decision did most of the bioinformatic
analysis Hassler was another student who
helped him make uh
some of the libraries Huang helped in
doing most of the protein data Christina
Randall Cristiano
is has been instrumental in providing a
lot of benefit support
and trying to do the Discord and read
analysis Randy is a clinician on this
project and Paul Lambert is a Godfather
of HPV and he has
primarily being very instrumental in
supporting most of the work that has
been done
and my love uh thank you for your time
and I will take
any questions that you have thank you Dr
goldpold I are for your time today and
for your important research and before
we go I want to thank our audience for
joining us today we would appreciate
your participation in answering a few
final polling questions to record your
answers click on the option on the
screen
our first pulling question do you
regularly generate libraries for NGS for
your laboratory yes or no I will give
you a few moments to answer
our next question are you considering
investing in NGS workflow automation
and finally would you like to receive
further information about magic prep NGS
sample preparation systems
thank you so much for participating in
those polling questions I'd also like to
take a moment and thank our sponsors
tcam for sponsoring today's webinar
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until October 6 2024
laboratory alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
bye-bye